яблуневих садах фермера нільса
мортенсена станьте когось свенд борга
треба відвідав від трава стала занадто
високу
його трактор про тебе між вами поряд і
дерил проте за кормом не кований травня
трактор ви кори стоїть gps-сигнал і
сенсори то рухайся по
запрограмованого маршруту
треба лиж і над і снуд і кнопку sel сама
ти чого так давно хоч і в трактор точно
видати мериді закохана в тому цілі
таку монотонну роботу з дня на день
раніше з чупс після ти всю траву на
тигель ansi потрібно було працювати 3
днів після одесі mk1 розлученням не результат
шум про автоматичний трактор, який ви
знайшли в нідерландах давайте таких
трактори вже чує на поля для гольфу
об і трава завжди було акуратно
підстриженої тепер мортенсен за вчать
джордж as a його трактор процесу бутіка
і погоди ми не треба було q8 найму ти про
його до нової роботи а так я економлю на
платі протеїнів криті як привчити він
avid technology with бороти роботу у
людей однак у рубриці безпілотних машин
адже перука в іншому у самохідний
трактор в цю і людей вигляд монотонної
роботи тракту робот теле кита чому
покаже ювелірною точністю мій трактор
законом це маусі обидва віскі найман їх
супротивники у працях абу-дабі лише
афективну тпр фермеру не лісу
мортенсена не треба трубу вати сім пар
заходи bespeco сенсора і зуб мати
трактор я кочурів там наяву шлях досвід та
ті люди на вирубних вбити, а ще контроль
на техніку з орди вирішуватиметься
лютий 0